So Terry, what was your aha moment?
I know that you said you didn't want to lose her,
but what was it for you?
I'm going to be perfectly honest here,
when the marriage was over, I was like, okay, that's it.
Then I'm done.
And, but a little voice told me that it was everyone else,
everyone else was my issue.
And it changed when it really really cracked the egg
that said, this is me,
and I called a friend and he was my counselor and my pastor
and he said Terry,
I can't tell you you're going to get your wife back,
your wife is probably gone forever,
but you need to get better for you.
Now, you got to understand,
for a man that was a watershed moment,
for me, I always did good things to get,
you know, to get cookies, so to speak,
you always, you work out so you can look like this,
you do nice things, so you can get sex.
You go to work so you can get money.
Wait a minute.
So you can get the girl.
You know, just actually improving myself just to improve.
That was like, wait a minute, he said, hey man,
this is about you,
'cause you probably going to be alone and you still,
are going to be stuck in your problem.
And I realized, listen,
I didn't even go to rehab to get her back.
But what happened was while I was fixing myself,
we reunited and it just, it became a,
now it could have went the other way,
that's still Rebecca's choice,
it was always Rebecca's choice
whether she wanted to be here or not.
So.
Yes, and there were many times Drew that,
hey I kept plane tickets in my hand,
but I'm thankful I was laying in bed last night,
playing the song I love called "Grateful".
And all I was thinking was how grateful I am
that I still have Terry.
I mean.
(audience applauding)
I really appreciate this conversation,
but you have your children, this is all out there,
where do they fall into that now that
the cat's out of the bag?
Yes, well, you know, part of our counseling
and one of the things that our counselors told us to do
was to actually talk to each one of our kids
and explain it at their level.
And we want to make sure that they knew
that this was not about them,
this was not their issue,
this is something a daddy and mommy are working through.
Right and this is a 12-step model
that's used with sex addiction.
So it deals with, you know,
talking to the victims of your behavior,
and that included our children.
Yeah. - Yeah.
Okay, on a last note
I just want to say, you guys have brought
a lot of joy and levity and honesty in all of this,
and how do you guys laugh,
how do you guys just kick all the bags, lighten up,
keep it real, have a good time,
how do you do it?
Well, he's a bag of jokes every single day.
My husband brings the fun
and I bring the structure, I always say.
We joke a lot, we make fun of each other.
Generally we just like each other.
And I even said to him, I said,
even if you left me and married someone else,
I'd still be your best friend,
because I know you better than anyone else.
Now, she's not getting everything I worked for though,
it's not fair.
That's the humor I'm talking about,
and we all need it to survive.
Terry and Rebecca, I am so grateful for this conversation,
and I applaud your guys's choice.
And I just think you're awesome,
thank you so much, Rebecca and Terry,
Wow, thank you so much
"Stronger Together", the audio-only memoir
by Terry Crews and Rebecca King Crews is available now,
exclusively on Audible, what a powerhouse!
Thank you so much you guys.
Thank you Drew. - Thank you Drew.
Thank you so so much.
You're the best!
(upbeat music)